joining us on the program is captain
tom's great nephew
tant abelet tan great to see you um
i'm i'm another hello i'm very well and
i was going to ask exactly the same
same question of you i mean this must be
an incredibly sad day
for you and the rest of the family but
but sadness tinged with an incredible
amount of pride i suspect
absolutely i mean let's not get away
from it
um captain tom moore has has touched the
heart of the nation
and he's he's done so much in such
short periods and such a long period of
time as well i mean
i i feel honored to be his great
grandson
in terms of everything that he's
achieved and everything that he's done
not only in the last year but but in his
lifetime which has been phenomenal
i think you know some standout memories
is
is not only raising and the
determination never to give up
when when raising that much money for
the charities but then
everything that's happened this year has
just been mind-blowingly
awesome really um take us all the way
back then to
to first lock down last year i don't
want to dwell on i'm sure you don't want
to dwell on it either but
but the gestation of an idea that
ultimately ended up raising
tens of millions of pounds came from the
man's
walk around his garden
well this is it i mean it's such a
you know at a time when i think the
nation really needed something
as a little bit of a pick-me-up and a
good news story um it started as a joke
um with his immediate family of you know
maybe
they could get to 100 laps and you know
raise a hundred pounds and then it came
to a thousand pounds
and then the nation just latched on to
it
um and i think they needed to to see and
experience you know a little bit of hope
and then
you know the money kept on rolling in
and
there's glimpses of what tom was like as
a person and
it's really important to say that
everything that you've seen on
television everything that you've seen
on the interviews that he's done is tom
um
he is the tom i i know and love um it
just hasn't changed
at all um and such a humble
and inspiring i think sometimes the word
legend or national hero is kind of on
national treasure is
sometimes overused but in this case it
really has
you know touched the nation inspired the
nation
what it's also done you know from from
quite a small beginning is
inspired other people to do their own
challenges inspired people
to raise money for the nhs i think it
was 30 38 million
that it the total actually came in the
end which is just a huge
huge achievement in itself not to
mention
this you know number one with michael
ball um an
england you know meeting um
uh lewis hamilton united meeting the
queen which i think was probably his
biggest biggest honor
and i'm actually having that that one
one to one
five minutes with uh socially distance
of course with with the queen
i think um was was a huge honor for him
it was clearly a a life well lived i do
wonder though
um how did he cope with being thrust
into
the spotlight you know an incredible
pace he went from
enjoying retirement to being a media
figure faded around the world
very very quickly i wonder if at times
it might might even have been something
of an inconvenience but it strikes me
that this
of all men was one with a sense of duty
and he felt that it was his his duty to
carry on in the path that he'd begun
yeah absolutely um just to answer your
question i think
you know when when we spoke um spoke in
august i think it was
um i think i said he was the most
probably the most famous man in the
world
um you know rubbing shoulders with david
beckham but
he would never have seen that as he
would have seen that as
you know something that oh that's nice
you know that's good
as long as we're doing the right thing
and i think that's where your
your comment is spot on in terms of the
the duty behind it
and the the the caringness and the
embedded you know reason datra that says
we we must go on you know everyone needs
a bit of a cheer up everyone needs
something to inspire them and you know
if i can play a little part then i'm
pleased with that i'm really pleased
with that
and you know everything's fantastic you
know the the spitfire's going
going over the flybys you know i i don't
think
i don't think you could have wished for
a most
amazing and and of end of life to
to the end of the year for the uh that
last year
i i think i agree um look on behalf of
all of us here we're
honestly very sorry for your loss but
thanks for for coming on once again and
sharing
your memories of i think what my common
consent
is a great man indeed tan thanks again
thank you
i really appreciate it and can i just
can i also just say very quickly thank
you for
for everyone to reach out for me and and
the family on social media my
instagram's gone
absolutely nuts and thank you for
everyone for caring and
you know lisa i knew i knew tom for
all my life and i'm just pleased to have
shared him
with with the nation and and hope it's
actually picked pick people up so
say thank you all and stay strong and
remember tomorrow will be better
thank you wise what's uh thanks again